hello guys I'm Ryan Wright tonight
Taylor Bradley Taylor Bradley and I are
gonna check out and I'm excited for
Taylor's opinions on these funny Donald
Trump compilation Donald Trump this vine
compilation' Donald Trump funny moments
suck all right here we go a lot of
people out in California are not really
liking Donald Trump too much so let's
see how much more he can make himself
look like an ass I'm really rich I'm
sure that Mexicans we have people that
are stupid
Donald Trump has been saying that he
will run for president as a Republican I
just assumed he was running as a joke I
am pretty pathetic and ugly this is why
our country's in trouble
sit down sit down
China China China China China if he Baca
were my daughter perhaps I'd be dating
her gently fart on your screen
I will talk to you after the deuce
wheter it's time for you to get out
you're a total joke
why would [ __ ] you blinds
wait you always rise oh my god huh if I
get the nomination I'll win the Latino
vote I will win it
[ __ ] you guys I love my wiener
nobody loves my wiener like I do let's
make America great again and I said we
need to build a wall
the American Dream is dead
okay DT Wow oh my god sometimes I think
he can't say anything else that would
like top the next thing that he says and
it's not like he's taking baby steps up
that ladder he's just [ __ ] jumping to
the top of that ladder and it's like
every single time I hear something new
that he says I'm just like who who would
say that and tweet it they tweet it you
would want to try to cover up the fact
that you said that yeah absolutely I
mean I've heard some horrible things
that he's proposing that wall he wants
Mexico to pay for it right because that
makes sense that makes perfect sense
my idea of how Latinos like him in these
compilation clips I was watching was
just so ridiculous I don't know one
Latino that likes him and then what he
said about the Paris attacks like
however they happened and so that if
Paris had more if they had guns it would
have been a different story right
probably would have been a [ __ ] war if
that was the case right you know but
that's kind of how he has his that's
what his mentality is is that he wants
all of these it's like he's not afraid
to say anything but he's like that crazy
racist uncle who nobody invites to
things and he just comes and it's like
all of a sudden but the whole world is
listening to him right now and that's
the thing that's really frustrating me
it's like all these people are making
these videos and making all these joke
things but all it's doing is making him
more and more pop yeah actually the
worst thing I've ever heard him say was
in this video which thing if if his
daughter wasn't his daughter he was we
don't say that about your daughter well
what did she think what could she
possibly even say oh it's too far to
gross it was really gross but she is hot
I don't she is pretty hot I would Trump
that you know what I mean hysterical
yeah and then she pointed me in the
middle of sex and be like you're on fire
like you're you're fired you're fine oh
wow I think that's a new low for you
no really no fire I've been lower
okay so Seth Meyers when he was doing
that roast I actually watched different
clips of that roast and they
left out my very favorite one I feel
like you'll get a kick out of this my
favorite one was it was like Trump says
that he has a really good relationship
with the blacks and that might be true
if the blacks are the name of a white
family and he's just like totally
deadpan the entire time he's just like
and they're all roasting in videos very
like I don't I can't take it at first
when I heard Donald Trump was running
for president before I heard any of his
proposals I was actually like okay with
it I wasn't like this is a joke because
I was like Donald Trump is a man who's
made billions and he's all about
capitalism and I felt like okay he might
have something to contribute to helping
this country get back on track he's a
good businessman yeah but his people
skills are horrible horrible and it
doesn't work okay why would we have a
businessman running the president
running like the country like being the
president well you see that's where I
was kind of like on the other side of
that where I was like he's a businessman
so you know he's dealing with like all
this [ __ ] about America's economy I felt
like he might be have tips on how to
turn that around he had any political
background true that's the other side
after hearing his proposals I'm like
completely wrong no he is not the man
who everyone's saying hi everyone I'm
bumping into is like whether the
Republican or Democratic they're saying
that like Hillary Clinton looks like it
looks like a toss-up between Hillary and
Donald Trump you know I'm kind of hoping
for Bernie Sanders I'm hoping for Bernie
Sanders too but I know it's kind of a
long shot but I really want him I really
want young people to go out and vote
because if all the young people went out
and voted Bernie Sanders would win cuz
Bernie Sanders is also about society and
you know helping out people and
everything you know sees me criticizes
being like what's the word I don't know
like to democratic way do you know
Donald Trump all the way over here and
then you have Bernie Sanders all the way
over yeah they're like complete opposite
you have of the spectrum and I feel like
Hillary Clinton for the Democratic Party
has been meeting a good eveing round of
them yeah she has some conservative
values I just think she tries so hard to
be cool like that's off-putting to me
the other think Donald Trump tries too
hard to me well no other story
Donald Trump I hate him so yes he tries
too hard to do everything and doesn't
try hard enough to be a decent person
but Hillary Clinton like really tries
hard to be like cool and get the young
votes and stuff and I feel like that's
more alienating to young people than
anything else you see Donald Trump's so
much about being solution oriented but
he lacks understanding and compassion
for the for the American people right
and that is something a president really
needs yeah is the ability to truly
connect and truly understand you know an
American or just a person in general
right people but it seems like he
doesn't understand any yeah it just
seems all about business to him all the
time all that his own business yeah it's
not about anyone else's or what anyone
else thinks or once I like that they
threw some of the Kanye stuff in here
absolutely I love that Kanye's speech it
was so funny and so like powerful like
anytime anyone feels that passionately
about something and delivers a speech
I'm kind of awkward well Kanye gets
passionate about a lot of things you
know that's why I like Kanye yeah so
crazy it's passion about things you
shouldn't get so passionate about
sometimes yeah that's probably true
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
Chanel I'm glad you got to hear some of
our political point of views if you're
young and live in America please make
sure to vote for who you believe should
be president senators anyway if you guys
are new to the channel you can click
this button to subscribe to the real
Rejects become a rejected a Taylor
Bradley on her channel they just
launched a web series called italiano
americano you should check it out it's
some fun stuff go to her channel right
now she wrote and directed yeah me at me
and my boyfriend wrote and directed it
wrote directed and produced it it's her
work so go check it out I wanted to say
that since we're talking so much about
business yeah if you follow us on our
social networks if we get enough
followers we can get even more product
placement now I have been talking with a
lot of people who have less subscribers
than me we're getting like six grand
deals on brands I'm like what why am I
not getting I will gladly promote
something for 30 seconds you've been
asking about it forever I've been asking
about it forever look guys I'm willing
to be a sellout
it means making more money at least
you're honest
it's the American Way Hamid sure Donald
Trump would agree with you
yeah Trump and I we bump this no no no
no never again